I've reached the scheduled starting time
my name is doctor
mark Cummings and dr. Dasher asked me to
be the local host for today dr. Dasher
is in China with dr. Chen who is
scheduled to be our presenter today and
of course we're having communications
difficulty but hopefully that will be
straightened out in a minute or two as a
kind of a way to start today I think
it's important to take a little bit of a
historical perspective for the last
hundred years there's been a tension
between the Academy's view of
information which is that results are
published and shared for the Advancement
of science and the betterment of
humanity and a commercial and national
security view which seeks to capture
intellectual property for commercial
purposes or for national security
purposes recently that tension has
become very severe and it leads to a
question and I don't have an answer to
the question but I think it's important
to ask the question and it's possible
that some of you will have thoughts or
answers or considerations around this
question the question is how should the
Academy operate in this environment of
heightened tension around intellectual
property for commercial and national
security purposes it's something that
that I have to deal with in my
professional life kind of minute by
minute now as
students it's something that is I'm sure
at least some of you were thinking about
and trying to figure out what it means
for you as people in industry who are
here you have similar problems and for
leaders in the Academy this is a serious
question well we're still working on
communication so this is this is
something that we all have to struggle
with and we've seen a change in behavior
at Stanford in the last six to nine
months and we've seen a change in
behavior at many other universities
around the world in the last six to nine
months cooperative programs have been
cancelled and I'm sure some of you are
looking at the news from different
sources from different countries and
getting different opinions about what is
happening but it's something that we
that that we as and I'm just focusing on
this in terms of the Academy need to to
think about how we're going to deal with
our our speaker is scheduled for today
is dr. Chen who has an innovative way to
organize a university and he was going
to tell us about that and I'm hoping
that that's still possible do we have an
ETA
so maybe five minutes okay
so given that we have time and I know
that you're not prepared for this
because it was not on the agenda for
this meeting today and I don't know
whether you want to even talk about it
but yes whether the conference I attend
a few days ago you know back to big loud
enough that everybody can hear you
please it is I don't have or if you want
to come up here it's and you can we can
share the microphone and the decent
right the secretary as they lay out her
ideas number one is the freedom
defense define and denial SS of National
City the second idea she has this we
have to create channel so that the
United States and China would
communicate with each other through
different channels so that we understand
our motives because I believe this and
this understand automotive we are a free
and trusting saya T and on the other
hand China is a closed and from top-down
management the third ones you mentioned
this we have to come confident of
ourselves as United States we have to
create or out in the waves power and
everything that's what I can transmit to
you all countries okay so just for the
people who can't hear this previous
speaker was summarizing a talk given by
Condoleezza Rice and
stating a position about China which had
three pieces one which was to defend
capture and defend intellectual property
well I'm afraid I'm not going to be able
to summarize it is each one defense
define and defend defined and deny our
assets intellectual property is in the
second point the second fortune is we
have to go just Canyon towards three
words yeah this is we have the same
create a new to communicate for example
like so create a channel to communicate
I can give you an example actually when
China created Asian infrastructure
investment bank the United States does
not want to participate but breaches
participated so her opinion is such that
it be participating in the
infrastructure Bank investment bank that
we create the Asian country build them
up to be strong so that we can on an eco
stage with the China s variety right so
this created channel to communicate and
work with China instead of competing
with each other okay sorry create a
channel to communicate with China all
right does anybody else have a comment
or thought yes please the United is fine
but in the case of intellectual property
cyber theft is such a major issue can
you have effectively not so given that
cyber theft is such an issue in our
world today can we protect intellectual
property that's a question yeah I think
it's a good question
does anybody else have a comment they
would like to make on this subject
so go ahead Wow I know right for the
bombing of the US happens were supposed
to be a deal between the government and
inventor stating that if you disclose to
us then we give you the right to correct
attack that intervention on property for
20 years 17 years old that night so that
was the deal struck between the
entrepreneur the idea person and the
government and that should be the deal
that helps us innovate faster okay and
that is why innovators innovate if you
copy my idea it doesn't matter which
country you can copy my idea tomorrow I
will do it not write a single article
I'm not going to write any any story
nothing that died without that there's
no creativity so we had some nice women
and you tell me if I get it wrong of
course so I think you had two points one
and this is from the point of view of
the inventor that the idea of patent
protection was key from the very
earliest days of the founding of the
United States and that it's a deal and
the deal is if you disclose your
innovation in this structured way the
government will make sure that people
who want to use your idea have to give
you fair compensation and the speaker
suggests that without such a deal no
inventor will ever disclose
are we yes
okay so hopefully I will disappear from
the screen and professor - sure will
doctor - sure and dr. Chen will appear
and I will be here after the
presentation assuming that we everything
works now and if you want to continue
this discussion I'm happy to listen
doctor - sure please you're on Diggs
thanks very much for filling in a few
minutes
can everybody there in the room hear me
can you hear me yes okay great
come on good morning I'm here with dr.
Sean Chen who is the founder and
chairman of seus University and we're at
the CS university campus which is near
the city of Hangzhou in Henan Province
in China so this is really an amazing
story that I'm very glad that we have a
chance to share with you so dr. Chen is
the as I said the founder of this
University he his education is both in
from China and in the United States and
before starting the University he was a
serial entrepreneur he found in several
companies including some in the
hospitality industry and also a metal
door manufacturing business and created
the see us group in 1992 in 1998 he had
this passion to really build up
international education in China and he
was able to start out this university as
a joint venture between the existing
jeong-ja University and a university in
the US so they're celebrating their 20th
anniversary this week and now the
university which is independent has over
31,000 students
and a beautiful campus that really
should be a tourist attraction
it's absolutely drop-dead gorgeous set
of buildings and at nighttime where
they're lighted up it's it's even more
impressive I'm here because of a beating
bad dr. chan is hosting the joint
conference of the association of
universities of the asia-pacific and
also the international association of
university presidents and dr. Chen is
the president of the Association of the
universities of asia-pacific he's also
got some good Bay Area connections that
people might not know about
he is the China representative for plug
and play and he's helped open incubators
in Beijing in Shanghai and Hangzhou in
Xi'an inch engine in Hangzhou and in
other locations throughout China and so
he's very committed to building up
entrepreneurship among students in China
as well as international understanding
among students in China so let me turn
the microphone over to dr. Chen and as
he's getting started will switch to
SlideShare thanks very much for speaking
this morning sure sure I'm so happy and
so under the to speak please Stanford
students and just like a preacher say
and then you know a little bit on maybe
just first of all talk a little bit
about myself and my background yeah of
course this is a remote and there's a
salon teez sometimes so taking the
career web to work it out so if there is
a stop that we're working on something
technically I didn't know what about
kind of question that I'm not they're
showing a the first of all they'd be
okay for a little bit about my
background I show the slides out for
school just like a richer said this
beautiful campus myself but independent
myself Anna I was born in tongue chain
which is one of
very a beautiful city and the southwest
the night I grew up there and then uh
nineteen seven of course I I was born
sixty-one of course indefinitely on
earth and I really grew up in culture
China culturally but revolution against
so many people now that's the sort of
heart I for for China and many many
people since you know 1966 and they
stopped a higher education 1977 and a 78
was the first year to open up for
students for people to apply for
universities so 1978 unfortunately of
course I got into change in University
and studied the four years and then
basic Esaias
was my major then after that I went to
your like States
for my further education because of I
always loved education I choose to study
more under than enough education higher
education management so that was and
about you know hearing the time and when
I was study in the u.s. I always back
and forth you know under then between US
and China and I didn't really understand
try to start and more you know exchange
in education and the culture because of
a back and forth I got some opportunity
to get involved with some of her you
know earlier startup manufacturers in
Chongqing because I was my hometown I
I hope the started the an out of company
which is a cosmetic and as an of course
and I because I when I was and I didn't
doing intern in proper gamble but then I
recommended them to do something like
about of course which earlier days and a
Chinese people don't use like shampoo
the early days of course Chinese will
only use soap to for everything then
they say wonderful to properties are the
first manufacturer to introduce the
shampoo to China market you know you'll
have a few jobs you will get a lot of a
good you know for
and everything even like I shared with
Richard yesterday the first you know
product and I already for make is they
they called in a bearish improve just
like of course and then Chinese people
never use simple before and then that's
why the one I gave with him some
imagination just like a beer you get a
lot of foams and then the not so I try
to attract the people later we find a
movie star from Hong Kong and then we
made an another like sort of like softer
hair two hundred four hundred reason is
they know how to become straighter
shampoo so it's really and a popular
gets really and a heart in my I know you
know very hot demand even Chuck's after
lined up three to five days a to wait
and the to pick up the products that was
you know really successful earlier stood
up and which I helped in that here you
know as a partner in changing a later
time of course I started another may to
tour a company because of China real
states booming and everybody before they
buy furniture
they always own about a security door to
protect their their wealth so that was
another success so simple manufactured
before proper Campbell came to China was
the number one manufacturer in cosmetics
and in daily use and other goods still
tour course amazing stood or was also
another than the largest my adore
manufacturer in China you know I I hope
the business which of course 1484 for
for me and then later of course because
of my major in education
I always wondering and if you China grow
economically
before there's not enough education to
help another not to sustain the economy
to to make a better country and a better
a player for international community so
I thought of course if we shoot another
now is help the China in education then
from 1996 I started to come
um force in China and I try to find out
and how I can help and China education
it's that time of course most of our
China education is a very still you know
using very oh the model like a super
Union no model it's read of course an
affray decreed now famous for only
learning knowledge now not anything else
now they like in the u.s. we do deeper
arts we we you know promote the holistic
student-centered and education we're
around the knowledge force and then
basically and of course and then there's
our time Chinese students only focus on
you know whatever major courses they
have and uh that's what are they they
have to study you know memorization just
like our course everybody knows that's
what uh what do we do there I feel like
oh kids what I benefited of course I
went to live through the college and in
Oregon or later on away limit and I
later transferred to to UCLA all one of
my education is a small college and a
liberal arts really you know give me a
really good background and also you know
really you know by a comparison I agree
this is more innovative or you know
education model so I really like to
introduce that amount to China then I
came back and explore every cities where
I should allocate if I do education
later of course I consult an American
citizen I consult Education Ministry to
figure out they know at the middle of
ninety there's no policy no really
policy to for foreign company or foreign
individual to come to China to hire a
due to higher education there are some
people doing the like I know you know K
to 12 education
so basically understand that son and I
by explainable by talking to them and as
I know you know they say dumb person and
that would commended me if I go to I
promise
whichever's need more about higher
education of the NIE by talking and I
found out the Honan promise what was the
largest of
in population that time I believes over
100 million now on Honam province is 112
million in population also is autistic
Province in China we said you know 27
Dynasty in China 20th dynasty alone in
in this province and also eight Asian
the capital in China and a five of them
see this problem so majority of history
and it is from this province under then
ah because there are very inner parts of
China are now not very international not
very much connected that Ouisa you know
outside so I feel like another this is a
property that fate had better place and
I've been place mostly needed the course
under you know that times eighty percent
of this province and the farming you
know many many of them of course I never
even added a higher education so 1978 I
established a SES University because
this is a very inner parts that's why I
figured out of course another we how we
see us we can make a window and the
bridge to reach outside the world
understand how we can educate and others
and and and you know for under the
farmers kids I become a global citizen
so that's why I introduced the more the
more deeper arts education holistic
education to to choose to start from
this province the beginning was very
difficult big big challenge and the
people of course and then feel like is
so foreign to them and then non offer to
the concept Lana for you know even I can
evil arts education model being
practiced in the Western world for
hundreds over years but then nobody hurt
here of heard of and a lot times before
so what's the challenge you know so
local people and then I feel like a why
you come here
but why you will of course when I
describe to them what I want to do I
have beautiful international campus
because this is a very cultural
like I said that the first Chinese
emperor was or I mean our university sit
aside and as there's a lot of history
I've been questioned and then when you
talk to them about the koloko cities and
the way you talk to them about it really
beautiful international campus and
European streets and they feel like you
are talking not nonsense
but anyway it was difficult but and
after then now we we we started in 1998
and now it's 98 and away we are
celebrating our 20th anniversary and as
we for the past 20 years so we really
made to see us a really something we
were the first of course in the sign
before you University we grow from to
sell at to 200 students now to 31,000
maybe it goes through another Richard
maybe those are some slides yeah so I
think I think that the slides are ready
just for you to try looking yeah okay
yeah I I did a because the nine and
eight we established of course mean of
course a little bit under then some
single person as a foreign company or a
foreigner you come to China you have to
affiliate with Chinese and a higher
education ended you allowed to issue at
way so the best university and ingento
and in Hunan Province essential
University and also we agree order
University to issue you know Chinese
degree as well and American degree
American University is the best before
the hey State University which is a can
run up the Kansas one of the seven
Kansas and the Union for a state
university so that's how we you know
work together we were the first one to
accredited by a degree and a state the
debris console and Education Ministry
and the for time under garage with a
university to grant you know to
articulate American degree as well as a
Chinese degree we have oh just like of
course I at Stanford is always my dream
and now of course I when there are many
many times and as an Edina really
impressed me greatly and I think
I need like I know you know get enough
land he's now default I always say NSERC
sonata for three year and a five years
out of a thirty year or 50 year for 300
or 500 years so that's why I secure the
line even though walk was a later time I
still have some difficulty but I secured
about more than 400 acres land
that's why now half our land is not
being built that's really reserved for
memorial in the future
whoever / of course under the 30,000
students it's not what we want to grow
course we only in 20 years old under
then it's basically demand in this
province and also under the Wofford
become a very very popular students have
to have a very high score you know even
like outside of a provost and applicants
they have to have over a hundred to two
hundred sixty points more from our enemy
the nine no no coach students have to
happen like a fifty even up to eighty
points more that's that's why even you
know number for private school and a
China yo Eddie B to 100 is only about 80
or 85 students come to register but as
an our registration on a ratio is a
ninety seven point eight last year so
that means you reach one hundred only
one or two not coming so that's why made
our population high now we are trying to
control we're trying to because in China
you recruit students by Kota government
to give you a Kota if they give you one
hundred ACOTA
you cannot take the ones 101 or 9:00 at
night you have to take exactly what you
published so we only can return some
Kota to government so we can come show
your students population and say ask
it's very very popular every year who
have to reject about the first choice
our first choice of applicant eight or
seven thousand of people so anyway so
that we have also some international
students we have a you know seventeen
hundred faculty including a person and
then countries of forty fifty and you
know foreign faculty a majority of
American professors come to teach
American forces we basically we cover
all our majors we don't have a
culture otherwise we have almost
everything we also have we start the
master degree program potential
University since 208 so we also have
some you know course for the a degree as
well you know it's a little bit of a
setup about our university we have a
property only University and an earlier
a year and a nine in 1999
we established a 501 C another nonprofit
organization the foundation board as
understand of ammonia and also our
finishing one side you say is the genjo
university under then then another side
is a Ford hasted State University so we
have a two educational resource we have
you know education researcher from
Chinese University and also educational
resource from a u.s. University so we
sort of a Easter Midwest so that's
basically an hour notion of our higher
education a cesspool course was the one
funding they are University support and
then financially and everything so this
is sort of a city lab you know the
earlier time and we are radiation we
send you you can preset I know foreign
as we grow so big so famous and answer
the Mountaineer first amount need or
diversity inside of so on education feel
like we are so big cannot be a secondary
and a college under somebody
so one else in independent so end of
last year's we become independent we
still have a Foundation board and as and
we still have a four hey
State University to as a partner of
course we have a boy about close to 200
other international university partner
now and of course we just want to
introduce more degree partners that
means and they can issue another a
degree our campus students don't have to
go abroad they study for years our
credits and their credits to gain
Georgia Gris so recently what was
working with the University of Arizona
now to also start issue they're deeply
still sales group is the day of course
and still a the one to to support and
helping the university we have sixteen
schools America Colorado quick I want to
say for more time for you to ask a
questions and also we can discuss a lot
of current issues like a Richard nation
we can do more about how and commercial
in China or some often a foreign company
how they do in China so what kind of
cocaine into those issues so that's why
I don't want to go very quickly we have
Foundation Board and many a many of them
are on chimp or under than in the US
also honor them but like a vice friend
of vice promote Cola many many of course
of corporate leaders and also charity
leaders and then a mayor's and Adam all
kinds of people have four members
helping us why see us become successful
and I guess huge Jenna then now you know
contribution due to our or member they
basically can be giving a lot of a big
help raising money not a lot but I think
also raising the resource to support
osseous so that's why we see Anna did
not see us is it's a fusion of east west
and as there is of course in than in
China you get a lot of or into culture
or you get a lot of or your resource in
China but a Western elements and then
resources are not enough without really
all the members helping us tremendously
they did a lot of programs leadership a
program a woman symposium or a future
woman Academy
many many of course and a mentor program
and you can them in and the many of them
so that's why I see us is it really a
very unique in terms of other programs
there we also has an occasional liberal
arts education we also an addenda you
know we totally are residential college
in China of course under than most of
like ISM even for our university proper
at ninety nine or more than ninety nine
percent of our students stay on so
that's why you build a university he's
not only build at classrooms library
or Apertura well do the streets the tiny
rooms we have hundreds we have a few
hundred or in a restaurant and an
untiring hall and also because and then
31,000 the plus other faculty stay on
this campus were like we are more like a
city we're not only like a school
because you have to build more more
dormitory but we a few Tom eatery
together we make a residential college
so this is the way we are now you know
we use in the classroom or cross order
enough study we around it and then you
know you know ability so many many
things we basically put into residential
college to do under than owning our
professional school are doing a majors
for them but I can residential college
basically doing a lot of
entrepreneurship innovation or programs
and everything so that's why I see us
and a very different model that's why
the very successful
all right education about its best which
is like I said and the deeper arts
education of course you are very
familiar with that I don't wanna go in
depth and and you know extra curricular
activities basically are more like a
relation it's another coach Hartman
basically made a very you know cultural
impact and even for on our buildings and
we may do some anymore exaggeration I
you know impact another visual impact is
also very important for our students
growth I don't know I could go through
another nerdy Poe arts education the
module and then age wanna see I'm we can
talk something more in if you need we do
a lot of social responsibility this is a
wall you know some of the pictures from
this one the water conference we even
invite many Nobel Prize and winner to
talk about as a wave and we even started
earlier with you know vice for in the
Air Corps to you know to promote and our
environment issue minamino earlier
earlier in a year in a twenty twenty
years ago we also because we are and
then our university location and a a
burst a place about first the Chinese
emperor so we every year
we do like that Chinese emperor culture
symposium so we do a lot of or you know
you invite a many many famous speaker
you know we want of course introducing
more about a Western culture as well as
in a traditional as well to help our
students our Chinese we always invite
because we are located in a very sort of
a little bit loud in Beijing Shanghai
and at the big cities and sometimes you
don't get a much resource from you know
you know be curvy and a VIP so we have
you know VIP a lecture a service so
every Wednesday we don't have afternoon
we don't have class we always invite are
many many famous speakers to really help
us students to open their mind and our
to help them to to say what is really in
the world I my vision to do a different
education especially trying to help
students are to attain a true knowledge
to knowledge of everything - Naja of
economics and researching you know
culture everything so that's why we
invite speakers to come to really give
them now the sensors you know knowledge
this is basically arts education because
as I said we have a many module many
many elements of how the deeper arts
education we emphasize some sports under
than arts under the music very heavily
so as what we're very strong we have a
two symphony group and we're very top of
a competition of many ports many many
and a tongue sing under the music was
really a one of their standard enough
from a CS university a pretty famous for
many of them
sports and this deserves an hour
Olympic and I didn't know your very
every a very high class we do we do
everything we even do a high table it
course we teach our students how to eat
west through food how to use and the
forks on how to dress how to date I mean
a lot of things and it's supposed to
t-tom and in basic education even
educated you know how Chinese some
sometimes some of their education
elements is now an out of town enough
but I think we have to make it up as
Orion for higher education especially
under how you can carry on better manner
courtesy when you do with other people
we do a lot of free market and a we do a
lot of international culture week so
every under the night year we have every
month we have a same activities
international culture we can die every
day so much other than exhibition film
performers lectures so really helping
students to to gain multinational
culture in the world this is our charity
banquet we do that as well under now so
we help Anna students to understand how
to do charity work and how to reach many
to do other than social responsibility
we are very different very much like a
you know regular Western University and
a lot of our activities events and then
you are familiar our opening school
opening was the biggest we always invite
the top notch speakers to really impact
students to initiators and students in
to say us very special culture this is
the Kendall night under than 2000 you
know senior students under them to
welcome honor than eight or nine
thousand the freshmen so over 10,000
students light a candle
using this kind of a cup early cultural
ceremony to initiate them into this is
very special place of CEA's graduation
for everybody has graduation graduation
of course we have a lot we eat we give a
lot of scholarship for them to go study
up every year we send about four or five
hundred students and then abroad we
might we encourage them to have long
term short term
international experience as
international university that's what he
really promote very hey
swim for we don't swing coded appearance
back because we this is designed by
American swimming team and as in a very
top notch and German took knowledge but
only of course in and China 208 Olympic
they don't allow another now you know
Olympic and he knows you know a fleet to
go out of patrons week they help us to
design this supposed uses as a practice
and we agree in a wonderful one for
ourselves so this is a student center
under this logically is our Russian
Square isn't watching we have a 12
European streets this is a real Russian
streets we have this is a Spanish Street
course on and all of them up upper part
are not upstairs it's a dormitory under
the first floor are the shops under than
actually two gave to students to open
the coffee shop stores and all kinds of
restaurants and entrepreneurship so we
are pretty because on the dates except
by a university ready encourage students
to become entrepreneur under themselves
just like using my and and example
everything myself
then I I figured out how I can help
China through education so that's why I
wanted my students also you know have an
entrepreneur and a spirit and then so
the need for they can become successful
they can do more social work and then
now to help others so that's how we
design this and the twelve utopian
streets this way sure this is of course
probably Peter you have a friend Ralph a
German we have Italian you have a London
great what the minimap of course maybe
didn't show you enough pictures we have
a three chakram failed because sports
are very far bigger sports University
with this is a human endure really good
the facility every facility is you see
as air conditioning so that's why
another now our first it is immuno of
much the super under than the many other
stores
of where were they only University in
this province have gone off major our
work with American golf college in from
Arizona I mean from Florida of this is
we we also have 12 European streets we
also have aid we called a thin garden
this is Chinese garden French German a
hombro agree Canada so that's basically
every card and not only nine skipping
are more so architect and other and a
design so that's why I see us is a
beautiful campus is now the only
building lined up of buildings but more
cultural campus this is an industry
actually well because we you see sure we
have a river passing by just pretty much
like a McClendon you know a big bang and
a similar so this is a London Street
beautiful and beautiful streets inside a
lot of London pass their approach even
those fake but again we just made
invitation why we make a a European
streets first when I come to this
province I found out majority of our
students are from farming community I
mean they never have opportunity to go
abroad well I never you can imagine they
how do I make a International University
if they don't even go abroad so I figure
you for they cannot go top course one
made of 90s I mean China school not so
open now so another grow and are now so
developed and as a know like now of
course and then everybody have money
they travel around so zalta masucci if
they III that and I say if they cannot
go abroad they cannot go say other
country let me just bring all in an
international Camino or every other than
our country in to this province
so students at least have opportunity to
say what it is for if used in Spanish
treat everything signs everything's in
Spanish under the know of French Street
everything's in French so that's why
Anna Chinese students sometimes they say
foreign letters they feel like I saw in
all English actually us how we help them
to understand at the different sanam of
stiff on the streets
this our library and the evening courses
we have funding we have one another this
is a South by a phantom Park we have a
North Mountain Park even a more amazing
but I inside he's still a little bit
under construction so this is of course
we want to make a nice place for the
future under the manpower talents it's
not of course you only squeeze some
knowledge to them especially you want to
grow them in different environment they
have seen the best of everything so
that's why they can be more creative
more innovative this our music school
under the nursery and a beautiful
theater in it you know this is a wall
you can't even like evening you know
they can do like music notes and a
musica arm so that's why in the building
is like a music box
this is our classrooms of course is all
our the middle is our administration
building and administration building as
what I could really I you know China
popular fan building one side look like
a chairman another side look like a
White House so or if our students they
all come to meet me either you meet me
in the chemists square or you meet me in
the White House so you know personal
didn't feel like a shiny our shoes are
crazy weird like oh under than it's none
of them's ingento but anyway this is a
basically an a our classrooms in the
module this is a well because we do a
lot of the support of course did a woman
Academy and every year we gather five
women students and other mothers
together
a week and help women a students to grow
better to accuse the bias and the
prejudice to them this is like we have a
future Information Technology Institute
like 50 school so some more like how we
do the pillars go to cut a last mile of
our education our graduates and stated
Dimity needs of a corporate are there
some gap how we can shorten that as
there's a lot of her we also know you
know this is a China called a CO - Envy
they are according I fly tech and then
basically is one
the best AI company in China so we now
post work with many many top company
have them to teach major courses and as
and now we teach another basic so
basically we like you know just like
Google like Google engineer to teach all
under than whatever ai courses then out
University professor to teach because
they're more innovative to have a more
frown eye and a knowledge so anyway this
is a new school we set that up we want
to set up many many schools ways at the
top not another not corporate in the
world we receive another lots lots
I don't need cannot even describe
another no no with many many years under
than a CCTV and English English speech
it was simply because we are reissue
American degree our students English is
good but also we have many years under
than China Chinese debating champion as
well we have to beat everybody web to a
wing over
Ching hua university beijing university
even now and of course in english about
course in chinese debating now chinese
debate he because it's international
chinese debating Harvard University
Stanford and then everybody join so we
have to beat everybody so see us is
really we rope at lunch in the robust
yesterday and as International
Accounting contest so many so many other
than different things nationally
internationally
that's why Anna's Education Ministry
says and then see us phenomena needs to
be studied how could the your students
are not at the top students in China but
I can you won so many awards and
hundreds of words a year and as a new
really bring students and potential to
make them something so that's why but
course I'm not kind of you know take a
time to mention so many so many
achievements we have under the now you
know stand out and then there's so much
in the educational circle in China even
because even we provide and because our
English is really good we provide course
hundreds of speakers to many many China
National Conference of good amid Oh Bill
Gates this is basically we our students
on it in a students
even graduates as a personal manager for
many many leaders many many another now
you know I know
so basically we have a lot of our boards
even like cut down Dante
on the right hand right hand side you
increase our garages when an Olympic
champion and up by and a javelin so we
we really produce a lot of powerful
graduates and really an agency with some
of the not a certain type of a really
top profession or in a hero Center than
some or something and in their own work
field anyway so I school is allowed
under the night I didn't know of course
and then talked and a lot more and as an
I like to you know it's put some time so
for for students for audience to ask
questions so we can discuss what's what
is your interest well thank you dr. Chen
actually or let me ask a couple of
questions and say a couple of things
first please go ahead yeah this is so
truly an amazing place and the more you
hear about it the more amazing it really
becomes as as an entrepreneurship
problem this is getting into an
established industry right the
university education had been going on
in China and there are severe
competitors there are always incredible
competition for government resources and
it takes at least 10 or 12 years to show
the results of a new university approach
because you have to let people graduate
and go out and work and see how they do
so it is absolutely amazing what dr.
Chen has done here I have a couple of
questions I want to ask first of all I
want to ask if you're seeing changes now
about what students need now that they
but that's different from what they used
to be right especially this province I
was willing to come to this a poor
province another now to help education
I feel at that time if I can change this
province through education under than
the world there will be a better China
because under the nuke you can
understand how sometimes and the farmers
kids are very conservative they have not
stayed enough outside the world so they
definitely honor them through and I see
us you can see a change because
understand we have for you know hundreds
hundreds of other than successful
graduates even you know even in terms of
entrepreneurship we you know a couple
years ago we you know hope we helped an
anomaly you know a conference we invited
about first 100 anomaly who made the 100
million yen and a successfully through
their own business a deafening and of
course a very sharing of how other days
how they started only a free market in
from see us then grow and I didn't to
such a big business for themselves and
as indefinite that's definitely a change
srimant see us platform and education
okay and my second question before I
give the floor to mark fuhrman it is
really ask you for advice for a foreign
entrepreneurs at a highly regulated
industry what kind of advice would you
give to people about how to work with
the government here well I work with the
Chinese government
right I know Chinese government actually
gradually more and more as they promise
of course under than they say one of the
our treati a negotiation recently is us
of course wanna china be more open you
know in a certain industry was not
opened even for the past many years
because china one of course have
promised to open more that's one or two
direction i believe of course an out by
the pressure of international community
you know if you charge are not growing
up as a bigger country and a bigger
player definitely needs to be i big a
better player and in there the community
so I believe in us not China can open
now this is actually challenging
question it's basically many many
foreign company come a bigger difficulty
is a you know Chinese and an environment
and especially Chinese business
environments are very complicated it's
now like I'm so directly in the Western
world because of this complication many
people many foreign company the
beginning they come they just get lost
and sometimes they lose but you still
say many foreign company and are very
successful made a lot of more money
because of their management it because
of to take a knowledge and an advantage
because I'll for you know course and
then of course a market demand you know
there are a lot of you know you know
China now many people for money
you look or not last week I was you know
having a meeting in Japan they just
faking it national holiday anime holiday
they bought a whole toilet off the whole
store I mean they're they don't even
they just basically stock and then you
know five times and then regular time
understand they just bought all so
everywhere they go and and there they
buy everything I believe if something in
Edina in a quality or take a knowledge
in a high demand and as they re there is
a market of course your questions are
how to deal with government that's a
difficulty one not only for foreign
company even for me myself government is
really it's a it's not only say
bureaucracy different a different
different period of time the beginning
when I come back to China and the person
in China at that time is basically now
really and a regulated not very much and
then if you have a good relationship you
buy you buy on dying people I don't say
in a corruption if you get a good
relationship you get them information
you get a you know because the
government control a power can come to
another basically and uh they are alone
or for information so if you I
especially approval under than
everything you knew you you you do you
need a kid approval from them so you
know getting approval and a dust and a
big another resource plan for you
because now under than you know a lot of
limits it's changed of course and
everything is in the platform
but even though you know this is sort of
still a Chinese customs culture
you still need have you know good
relationship and you know I say
foreigner because of a language because
of culture if you do something you
better have a Chinese and a either
partner or hire some of a local Chinese
people to help you out to do PR I mean
the PR work and it's not only another
typical in China but in even in the u.s.
course you always every company have a
PR section PR manager under them that's
why Public Relation is not only into
government you know to our to a lot of
different sectors of society as well so
on my device with a you know you know
using no code using you know also on and
then just like myself under then I come
I spend a lot of time to do PR to let
the government and L what I do and as in
the one of what I can do better for
local community and our society okay
thank you very much
so mark as I turned the floor to you for
a second I first of all what to say
thank you very much for anchoring from
the Stanford's hi everyone dr. mark
Cummings has been a very respected
associate for me for a long time we have
been together in a number of
universities in China as well as working
on projects here and Mark is extremely
committed to new types of solutions to
Internet policy and I'm delighted that
you can be here mark mark would you move
that the computer so that we can see you
and then maybe you can turn it around
and let us see the audience all right I
don't know if this is working
there you go down see okay so the camera
is working and I can turn it to focus on
the audience all right but just we're
seeing the ceiling first I would like to
ask but you know every we're seeing the
ceiling just turn them house there you
go
move a little bit further well I'm
afraid if I move it
conditions here that's about it that's
about as good as I can do okay at least
you've got a section of the audience
yeah so I'd like to open it up first to
the students in the room do you have any
questions for dr. Chen or dr. - sure
that's not a that's not a reason to run
away it's just a an opportunity yes okay
so let me repeat the question
the first the first question dr. Chen is
about your admission requirements what
are how would you characterize your
admission requirements is that that
correctly yes you know our University at
the mission requirements of course I
want to talk a little bit about the
China higher education China has an of
course in a three category of a higher
education biggest one it's a public
university about the sixty five sixty
eight percent on another one is a
private university domestic we call the
domestic and private university roughly
about a twenty percent
the third category we call a sign of
foreign sino foreign is basically like a
Shanghai New York
- no daehan Sia's see us was the first
one of course on and for this category
you know open up and the first
university to issue American patrocle 3y
I talked about the high street category
because on an earlier time when China of
course on and you know in the u.s. you
automatically and I you
or university and I'd like Stanford and
a new recruit that you send your
admission because you make your own
decision China of course in the 80
missions to say is not solely by a
university in in consumption disease
made a pie and a government course to
every promise has a government agency to
to to managing a recruitment first and
of course in the day they divide into a
three tier school number one of course
the public a university top-notch
university and of course they recruit
the first they crew the highest score
course every year at July a minute July
and June 7 8 9 now is the same in July 7
July 8th are not a national examination
day students take examination and then
then about about a couple of weeks later
the L of them get a score no only once
examination not like a question the u.s.
you take a a CT SAT many times and so
after you get a score then are you
student government of course and it's I
don't
although the process like examination
scores you know now by I'm not by done
by University done by government so then
they publish that each one's score and
as indicated in the notice of how many
scores you have how much the scores you
have then you according to the score you
have then you apply that moment you
apply is not of cause a year before
Stanford you apply by in a December then
you apply for which school are you
you wanna go according to and how much
scores you have if you have a really top
notch you want to go to chin why you
diversification University or you have a
medium and you want to go this and code
odd so that's what it is and then the
process then government gave on every
University Cota just like earlier I
mentioned the if they gave you 100 ACOTA
you cannot take the 101 or line deny you
have to take exactly that what is a
publish to the public for instance to
see us I have over 9,000 or 10,000 the
Cota so that's why our code
hi and then you know I mean you cannot
imagine you know a regular universe like
us and even like to recruit that nine or
ten solid in the students you know for
someone to come and I still large number
for one school of course we are in the a
in a province under than every year
there for almost 1 million
you know grad you know high school
graduates to apply for colleges so
that's why I'm not enough an ecologist
here that's why our score gets high and
then that's also difficulty for students
to go to a university in this province
so native mission is basically when the
government gave you notice of course
everyone then they used to do start
apply for then for us of course they
basically apply they don't send a
petition to us they update send an
application to government a platform and
as any government given out that
information to us and as then whoever
apply fuzzy for the hours focus when
when when the course wouldn't of course
it's one tier second tier were second
tier and a when a second tier to start
to recruit the government at unload all
those people who apply to us into our
computer then we also another make a
prince we have a 100 Kota they gave us
120 but even if they gave us 120 buddy
we still have to go by a score you know
if I you know then we have to pick up
the higher score first if we got enough
through our quota and we start from
there
sometimes even I could for instance if
you know we our score is we take of
people who are about 500 220 you know if
we start from 520 but if we we know that
one score sometimes there is a you know
10 20 people within one score there's
not many peoples and we have to take
them all but is where I'm wondering to
Dakota and then we're only into 22 101
but I think that last score is 100 or 25
or 20 and then does the score because
there is the five people or 10 people
apply to us we have taken them all that
means we have to increase our quota from
government because we have to take more
to be fair for everybody to get in
thank you thank you it was the second
job what was the second question so I
think you mentioned a lot about how the
university is trying to encourage
education but I'm very curious about
like like how is there any specific
industries I think I understand the
question so the focus of the question
and please correct me if I'm wrong is
entrepreneurship and the questioner is
asking about what industries your
graduates practice their
entrepreneurship in did I correctly
state your question thank you dr. Chen
did I did I make the question clear well
talk about entrepreneurship whatta what
the industry corrupt the graduates and
uh you know more on practice and
entrepreneurship you know just like I
said that we do the 12 European streets
many of our students start to you know
like a free market or even we have a box
and others store so we call about
stories basically and all the shelf are
a small boxes so our students should go
around figure out what kind of products
they can put in that into the box
the only they don't have to buy a lot
they don't have to pay the a lot of
stock but is ended by little if they try
the front without a box these students
five students want it we have a store
with only every every mini mini box so
they're in a box or get a free box so
you've gotta try the works then they buy
they take a few more parts or they kinda
take a whole store so so many many our
students are started from just simple
they take goods in a closing or or twos
or anything so and then after they are
successful and then they get a whole
store and after sex is host or the open
picker picker are now so many of them of
course
later time without more money more tab
to themselves now they do like an
Internet applause so they do more like a
you know online sharp stores so many of
our graduates are successful in online
shopping online course a human made of
course different specialty and or
special kinds or even like online under
than shopping for an international so
that was some question and an internet
and and then shopping was been in a big
one and of course as our statistic is
saying another many graduate because
maybe because and when they come to
campus we encourage them on the streets
to to to Anna work that's one of course
and our graduates because just like I
said we don't have agriculture we have
almost everything medicine PE arts
business law architect many many of them
so that's why our graduates serve all
kinds of Industry courses age especially
go to a whole world under them to work
not only work in China but they also
work everywhere you have do you have any
figures on how many of your students go
abroad for graduate study after they get
their undergraduate we love only about
five percent from our graduates you know
so far for so it out of the several
thousand student Brian right laughs
right so roughly and other than four or
five hundred than each year for long
term of course maturities do come to us
you know person and and that's why
sometimes when I travel I even I travel
to Africa and I somebody call me and I
say president and then then I was really
surprised how do you know I'm your
student and you also mentioned that
companies like I fly tech are teaching
some some of the advanced technology
classes here are they picking up any of
your students after after the students
graduate is yes is the local industry
really changing so that there is more
high tech industry here there are on
every city of course China promote in
innovation and entrepreneurship on earth
and since - Oh 15 a because of that a
huge big movement English honorable
mention I wanted to do something or visa
to another night of movement so they can
promote and abettor yeah definitely
every city compete with everyone to
introduce more I take a company to come
to the city because odds
I took the future they don't wanna of
course all the manufacturer and a makeup
pollution under than you know so
labor-intensive right so they -
everybody want to change and more
another profitable now I know the future
high-tech ok it's a you know it's a for
our students and I didn't before you
talk about high flight a attack what it
is of course we form AI school with them
under then we teach basic we teach him
you know for certain accord forces other
than you know on a general another
education courses and as a teach and
then a major courses professional
courses a laboratory under than are in
no intern practice so actually AI an
engineer a very very high demand is not
enough a course on emphasis and a
digital transformation and a whole and a
China huge that they they sort of a cup
of a million engineer and a computer
engineers and a pool of either Big Data
or artificial intelligence there's a
very very high demand I mean just don't
get enough graduates okay on every every
either good or bad and an average
achieve major if you major in this a I
another now on or or they take off so so
so that's why another we form this AI
school here okay thank you
next mark yes a question here school are
you more interested in the future in
establishing professional schools like
nursing law architecture business or
would your focus on being trying to
become an r1 research university so the
question is about graduate the graduate
program
and the questioner creates a dichotomy
on one side professional schools
medicine law and the other side is
research where and it characterizes it
in terms of the u.s. structure and our
one University and he says he's asking
are you trying to do one or the other
did I say it right yes yes and uh you
know I believe one of them we go both
and I'll hand my hand
we definitely as a regular University we
need a problem we need to produce a lot
of no professional talents we need other
doctors we need the engineer architect
engineering so we need of course money I
know then that still has a normal
society and and those kind of jobs do
you know available and that the demand
is there
of course we definitely cannot say we go
you know for no focal our professional
school and owning co and a focus on
research but and of course we say us
actually of course I didn't I mention
among the private schools in China were
one of the best research under the
university under the na as well we
beginning of course the first thirteen
years we didn't pay much attention for
the last ten years so really catch up
now the very many universities hire
full-time research and a professor and
we are the one of course we have a spot
seventy now reason which recently we
reduced to a like a forty-four time
research professor they don't teach then
they have only lectures but er than they
do only a research and the programs why
we reduce because another some of a
really professor really they don't
really do good job so we reduced it up
but okay and then research
scientifically research is one of the
high under the priority and also another
focus for our next 20 years development
even though we are doing good and in
terms of Anna members and Adam or are a
pure
article publishing under them you know
we are one of the best one panicking we
feel like a compete with public
university in China and we are Sophia
we're still so behind and as a private
school we don't get a funding from
government totally and 100% dependent on
tuition and also our own companies
support and also release money and
because we are now first twenty years we
want to get a better students so that's
why we we lowered our to to yishun our
tuition even though we have a very the
best of acidity good a professor or our
two years is the lowest but I don't know
how you're understanding this we are the
lowest among private school in China
also sign up for new schools in China we
only collect about 13,000 yen a year are
we we got approve of over 22,000 so this
way we can basically get many more
competitive among the private school
under here they cannot ago to a
top-notch school under then they will
come to us not only we tape in the
scholarship but our tuition is low
enough to be more attractive so let me
point out that you know one of the thing
about what dr. Chen is done that really
fits in more with social
entrepreneurship that with
entrepreneurship for a regular
for-profit company is that there's no
obvious exit pattern most of the startup
companies are created they grow and they
expect either to become a public company
or to be bought by some big company that
sort of the future is not really
possible for a university so how do you
see the road to sustainability or CS
universities well I know then just like
I said and they're not number one a
founder has to have a vision for a long
term on a for another nature patient
because it's a now of course even you
talk about and then you know regular
business you
do you have exit a plan of course
universities now we accept you know when
I first entered an open a university you
know become a famous and successful so
many company come watch to buy see us
and our Lauria group one of the you know
us and a company they've been keeping
following us Sanatana for many many
years now they keep coming back and as
in saying we want to invest in you and i
said well we don't want to make a profit
another I totally I don't want to make
as issue diversity wanna help in China
I wanna basically become a good school
so under than our graduates has voice
and now this degree will not push the
better way to change China would they
have a voice so we don't really have
course to say this sub course and then
university is other than like a company
and you could exit at it so like I said
and then when I do I see us is an out of
a three-year or five-year he's not a
fourth third a year or 50 year is for
300 or 500 years so that's why you want
to set up a foundation even the land
another than I really picture the huge
line I'm still you know trying to say of
course you look around our campus before
was a farm are around ourselves we can
get as much as the amount but now and
everywhere is being built in China now
around an hour you receiving our lowest
tempest was even occupied by so many
other people and we have to spend the
money kicking them out so it was
difficult if I don't get them the line a
secured a now you can imagine your
networking by land or even get a land or
even Lian will become so expensive so
that's basically you would really have
to have a long vision a longer vision
then I believe on a unit history
Stanford is not even a an earth day the
primary location are like an East Coast
but now I know under than Stanford and
make a Silicon Valley now I believe in I
see us not in a region and in the
primary location like a you know Beijing
Shanghai and I came and because of this
internet and does it really matter
distance anymore and I believe and a we
serve can better function another week
and do a better successful a work in the
future
so sustain other than you know become a
better school X in the school is always
our joys and as
we push you very hard and then we we
work very hard on it you know I suspect
there are other possible questions from
the audience but we're sort of near the
end of the time for the class so I'm
going to do something that is sort of
cheeky but I very much want to let dr.
Chen have something from Stanford and
say hey thank you very much for your
presence thank you so much the Richer to
giving me the opportunity to share you
know there's a lot of course we even
have another in touch touched up or than
I saw that we're gonna talk more about
the us-china trade and the
decommissioning and everything but we
really have to make a time and come back
and then because this wanted more so
focus on education but uh there's a lot
of current the issue and then invite
buddy but we all are interested under
them from most from Chinese people as
well as American people how we can build
a better relationship and because the
number one number two never can fight
and I think that your international
focus is exactly one of one-half of how
we'll get through this kind of difficult
time the other half is for us to try to
support it I'm very happy to meet dr.
Chen thank you so much Rosen thank you
for the gift so thank you thank you
other than everyone in the classroom so
let's keep in touch talk more so thank
you Richard it sounds you've got a
little bit of a cold I hope you take
care of you yeah yeah I'll live I think
thanks Warren I think everybody there's
some refreshments outside the auditorium
so please stay around and get to know
each other thanks everybody
thank you all bye bye bye okay bye bye